guten morgen leute aus berlin heute ist
freitag der dreizehnte nein es nicht ist
freitag der elfte glaube ich ja und ich
habe gerade indisches essen
das kann sie so herstellen würde ich
mein letzter arbeitstag wir müssen jetzt
mal kurz ihre ausfahrt steigen zur bank
fahren und danach heute in blanc kann
sich bei dem thema zeigen was wir
bestellt haben dass es ein bisschen
sorgen
und dann heute mal so verpuffen worten
haben auch mal wieder einen pott video
dabei ganz cool
bad orb
soll youtube man nie abgehoben aber als
war indisches essen was sie bestellt
aber wir können eigentlich auf das hier
ist
leider fand hektisch ab heute wieder
viel zu wenig geschlafen zwar
viereinhalb stunden glaube ich weiß
gestern bis halb fünf noch an den ltte
für main stream saß werden jetzt richtig
cool also alle leute die gerne die
screenshots für die gibt's was richtig
richtig nass sonntag 20 uhr soll dann
zum ersten mal reingehen noch ein
perfekt schleppe jeden tag hier
man fordert die treppe rauf und runter
den zweiten stock
ich schätze dass so ein geklaut wird
so hat geklingelt das müsste jetzt das
essen sein
bin mal gespannt aufzug für den dritten
stock in dem zweiten vielleicht doch
nicht das essen soll jetzt aber es hat
eiskalt zweieinhalb stunden gedauert
aber jetzt muss sie auch aus ersten ich
habe einfach nicht gefrühstückt und ist
jetzt schon 14 uhr 30 oder sind so leute
dass du hast so weit von unserem
mittagessen
jetzt habe ich noch ein paar fragen für
euch bzw ihr hattet fragen für mich
unter dem hashtag question of twitter
gebeten ihre fragen zu stellen und die
wollen jetzt ganz gerne beantworten und
ich sage euch passt auch gleich kommt
nun richtig geile szenen in diesem blog
also epische richtig episch möchte sky
news uk mache aber so ein paar fragen
mitnehmen hat mich jetzt gerade hier da
in unserem aufenthaltsraum im büro
bisschen davon gestohlen er fragt
meinung zum neuen soundtrack finde ich
episch also wirklich grün pains ist
hammer richtig richtig gut so viele tote
bäume fragt willst du mal wieder nach
köln kommen klar zu viel
ich bin kein break schon wieder in oslo
und zwar am 15
und am 19 also jetzt quasi in der
nächsten woche gleich zweimal in köln
mit revolver freiheit herrscht question
wenn du morgen früh auf irgendeinem
flecken erde auf bauen könntest es gibt
keine begrenzung wo wäre ich wohl wäre
es doppelt dick war wo wäre es ort und
dann einmal ff ich glaub mir meiner
familie ganz ehrlich also das ist der
ort auf den ich mich momentan am meisten
freude wie komisch aber irgendwie auch
cool familie würde ich sagen auf jeden
fall wie gesagt ausschlafen meine
geschwister sehen meine mutter sehen
mein vater sehen alle sehen freunde
besuchen wieder in der heimatstadt und
dann wenn ich ein bisschen mich
ausgeruht hab mal bisschen rumreisen
indien am liebsten ich liebend gerne im
januar nach indien gehen echt so für
eine oder zwei wochen kein doppel also
alle fragt hast du deinen play button
form bekommen und nein oder den nicht
bekommen dann habe ich anfang dezember
bestellt glaube ich vor einer woche und
eigentlich müsste der also youtube gibt
immer eine lieferzeit von acht bis zehn
wochen an
was hat ewig lang ist hatte jetzt mal zu
meiner familie stecken lassen
richtig geil wenn ich jetzt noch in
diesem monat den ich jetzt habe bis zum
23 januar noch einen play button
anhalten könnte welche sprachen da bist
du eine schule fragt ali wunderbar 27
grad ich einfach englisch latein
englisch urteil
ich hätte auf jeden fall spanischen der
schule belegen sollen absolventen der
schule belege war danach nach dem abi
sechs wochen in barcelona und spanisch
gelernt ziemlich gut ziemlich schnell
sogar
ich war sechs wochen auf b2 niveau was
hat ultraschnell ist also von null
gestartet und ich hätte wirklich
spanischen der studie belegen sollen und
nicht astrophysik der figur gewesen
ich habe damals nur astrophysik belegt
oder den naturwissenschaftlichen zwei
gewählt weil ein guter kumpel von mir
die einzige person nicht in meiner neuen
schule haben als kannte den zweig auch
belegt hat ganz ganz dumme entscheidung
vollkommen gegen meine interessen
entgegen meiner fähigkeiten voll nicht
hat in spanien zwölf viel viel mehr
gepunktet ich meinen sport eigentümer
der beste in meiner klasse aber wartet
in der naturwissenschaftlichen naja aber
das kann jetzt auch nicht mehr ändern
und wenn ich das nicht gemacht hätte ich
nicht ich hab das schon bewegen und zu
guter letzt anti anti made fragt have a
question hast du schon bestimmte planung
für die ferien und kannst du ski oder
snowboardfahren ski oder snowboard ich
kann skifahren
ich brauch glaube ich zumindest ich weiß
nicht ob es jedem so geht aber ich
brauche immer wenn ich auf skiern stehen
also zwei drei tage einen halben tag ist
mich wieder wohl fühlen aber lieber anti
thema ferienplanung ich habe in der tat
was geplant und zwar werde ich am 15 12
nach köln fahren zurück also ich sie am
zurück zu meiner familie am 15 bin ich
schon wieder in köln und am 16 bin ich
in berlin
für die stars prämiert
und
ja um 16 12 uhr bin ich in berlin bei
der star wars premiere und mit luca
sogar mit luca will bald in berlin war
dass das von mir und wollte das wird
richtig cool ohne wirz die form ich war
noch nie bei der kinopremiere jetzt zum
ersten mal das wird richtig richtig geil
ich freue mich darauf ja disney hat muss
immer wieder so eingeladen glaube ich
auf jeden fall danke disney filmen wird
bestimmt moschee im 19 schon wieder in
köln
im zwanzigsten ist dann die bruder vor
der premiere da bin ich auch mit luca
also angebots für kannte vilbel mehreren
aktionen die oper dann am 23
haben wir einen klassentreffen so eine
reunion mit meiner alten klasse die ich
jetzt auch drei jahre nicht mehr gesehen
habe also mit meiner alten abiturklasse
im abiturjahrgang treffen uns da wieder
in meiner heimatstadt und ich bin
gespannt wie die leute sich so
entwickelt haben aber leute wisst ihr
was ich kann da auf jeden fall erhobenen
hauptes und stolz hingehen weil ich mega
mega mega stolz bin auf alles was ich
mir jetzt quasi aufgebaut hat und am
allerschnellsten stolzes denn ich finde
einfach cool sagen was so als ich bin
wirklich stolz darauf was wir uns da
zusammen aufgebaut haben wollen dass ihr
das übrigen cool findet was ich hier
mache das unterhaltsam fehlt da bin ich
dankbar dafür dass sie dankbar dafür
dass ich stolz darauf sein kann weil wir
mehr zuschaut und das nur soweit die
pläne danach steht eigentlich nichts
mehr an keinen winterurlaub geplant
glaube ich ja silvester sind
wahrscheinlich in köln
also wenn ihr uns da treffen wald auf
den fall dass wir so weit von diesem
juni danke für alle fragen dann keine
fakten
danke an diesen ja auch für die
einladung ist übrigens kein powerplays
mit oder sowas sondern einfach eine
einladung zu diesem event ich habe jetzt
hier für nichts bekommen außer die
lichtschwerter diesem jahr ausgeliehen
haben ich habe übrigens 1 kaputt gemacht
aber sagt nicht weiß aber okay das
andere geschichte das war soweit von
heute eigentlich zuschauen wie sind es
wieder